vous n'avez pas l'impression que c'est
légèrement creux ça va elle le mérite
adam
pasqua ou est ce qu'elle va mal ça
c'était juste de la haganah
[Musique]
voilà pour commencer je voudrais vous
dire que je suis dit super content de
retrouver tous mes potes pour la virer
hivernal annuel de black v ner temps
j'ai envie de passer du tube en temps
avec chacun d'entre vous de partager
avec vos des des moments des moments
inoubliables et mais je le fais pour mes
soeurs il faut que j'avais trouvé ça
merde you diffusé aujourd'hui se trouve
pour la suite de wanted armes ont été au
chapitre de ses parties battant perdent
jamais caché ça aussi chez cet homme
josh frère d'anna et bêtes réfléchi
affectueux compliqué ok c'est quand tu
va installer des antennes relais ici je
commence à lui capté hoya pas de raisin
si j'ai un million trop de moi non plus
nickel mais ça ce n'est pas du rc hun
sen n'a ni mal moi je vous le dit saint
loup va finir par y arriver ou quoi
inquiet matt emilie jaoui soumah et
emilie matt emilie son ensemble
maintenant on dirait aimar est qu ils en
pensent quoi je crois que mike a déjà la
tête ailleurs citi
non certaines banques ces chenilles ya
peut-être d'autres entrées ah ouais il y
en a des millions mais elles sont toutes
fermées ni qu'elle va trouver d'autres
entrées est rentré dans ce bâtiment
glauque vous affectez 20 qu'elle va
mourir
le hcd christ trouble et ça fait bizarre
d'être de retour confiant à ça fait
bizarre ça fait bizarre
lui a bien oui sauf que j'ai un peu
froid oui cet endroit me donne la chair
de poule oui moi aussi c'est bizarre
d'être de retour ici
oui c'est parti on a trouvé d'entrée je
te tue mon gars au beau move up
oh là là le chalet immense mais c'est
évident qu'ils assistent son million
d'entrées 100 millions de morts
possibles dans un endroit vienne h là
oprean l'âge direct non elle n'est pas
là là justement pierre bru 7h et pour
quoi faire
allez on y va on y va on pousse alors où
ce qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière à nancy
je peux remonter à la fenêtre d'accord
ok très bien je suis chaud en brûle sur
des maisons dont je connais bien le
système parfait allons-y le pex garwood
quoi watts
moi ça m'a pété les oreilles tu déjà
voilà comme par hasard nickel
j'ai loupé la galerie j'ai peur vient
d'avoir supprimé un nom ouais
et c'est quoi ces croquer alors je suis
presque sûr d'avoir des autoroutes
ensuite des salles de bain tu pourrais
l'utiliser bas avec le break et je
comprends pas comment un déodorant pour
l'idée c'est un vaporisateur
ouais j'ai compris à lens clave comme on
fait avec les petits soldats comme on
fait quand on a 8 ans et demi qu'on est
demeuré olalalala non mais tu es moi
bordel tu es moi maintenant s'il vous
plaît un totem un nom ne dit pas qu'il
est noir ou rouge fer totem de pertes
weight nickel la perte potentielle d'un
ami cvo pleine eau c'est quoi ça c'est
quoi çà c deja [ __ ] dralha et le quota
de la salle de bains trouver un
déodorant bondoux faire un déodorant et
là bas la salle de bain fait à la fin
demain oh là là c'est moi qui joue lors
des cinématiques sans déconner watts
what do explique ou gaza s'est fait
emmener vous restez de porte tout de
suite allée du pacs est fermé ouais je
peux faire vous allez voir un psy
screamer genre une porte fait sourire
c'est fermé ouais ils sont de l'autre
côté ils parlent assez drôle
on va aller donc dans la pièce la grande
pièce un oh là là mais c'est quoi ces
bruits ou et la salle de bains voilà je
en train de visiter la maison la plus
chaude ou du monde j'aimerais trouver la
salle de bain ça ou pas c'est ça ou au
[ __ ] moi pas je suis tellement content
allez on s'en fout du top 3 pour une
plaque à aller prendre leur inferno
d'oran formelle
je me suis défoncé de merde faut qu'ils
arrêtent l'escrimeur faut qu'ils
arrêtent les [ __ ] de screamer bordel
au la travée poil et que des hauts lieux
oui bah tu te calmes j'arrive c'est pas
toi qui a pris tous les risques dans
cette maison alors n'oublions pas que
quelqu'un peut mourir brûlé las vegas et
ne voilà tous dans le chalet de la voile
et et où aller ah [ __ ] et se garder ce
qui la met du coup à cause de moi et
entre l'accès pense que tu veux fener
mettre en garde je vous ai vu non je dis
que j'ai vu moi moi je dis que j'ai vu
je t'ai vu qu est ce que tu faisais avec
même sur le chemin je vous ai vu quand
t'as bu avec le télescope
on s'est croisé on s'est trop longtemps
qu'on s'était pas vu alors gelé prise
dans mes bras
c'est interdit est ce qu'on lui dit être
lu approche plus jamais se marrent nov
ou est ce qu'on lui dit partant j'en
fais un peu trop facile continué avec ma
copine dans rolling stones ronnie wood
est dégagé ce bad parole ouais ben ça
c'est ça il n'y a rien eu d'autre c'est
moi je peux penser ce que tu veux c'est
un pays qui voit ses intentions en grec
j'adore que la natation le cuir tandis
que sa nouvelle copine et son ex arrive
à temps
personne ne veut marcher sur les
plates-bandes
elle est jalouse de a dit quelque chose
bien sûr c'était trop occupé à faire ta
kaunas thivras on dirait que tu es
grille de ne pas avoir reçu ça et toi tu
as réussi à faire partie de son troupeau
bravo jolie vache c'est pas très malin
comparer la reine du bal à une vache ok
donc les deux filles sont en train de
s'embrouiller [ __ ] la situation allait
bovine quoi ces deux couples on dirait
que sa copine à lui veut retourner avec
le mec de l'autre et son câble jouer ce
qu'on provoque way dans les tensions là
dans les tensions et les salles où tu
mets vraiment tout le monde malade et
jaloux emilie est trop fragile pour toi
c'est ça aulas lors je vis mon prénom
c'est cher et je me fous des ce que tu
peux et battant 20 sur 20 moi je vois ça
je t'en [ __ ] à moins quand tu galères
à pour trouver un boulot à quoi peuvent
bien servir les notes quand on est tous
les atouts que dame nature fait de nous
ce qui ne devrait même pas un pauvre
morceau de pain rassis avec ses fesses
un peu sérieuse car ce contrat pourquoi
aller déjà tu fermes ta bouche archie
comme l'inde
on encore sur l'histoire c'est plutôt
toi qui devrait arrêter de fourie ton
sale nez dans les affaires des autres
maintenant c'est moi qui vais m'en
occuper des affaires tu vas voir ce soit
normal parce qu'elle a su prête c'est
pas pour ça qu'on est venus ici ça va
rien arranger
voilà j'adore besoin d'une petite pause
non puis-je l'adorent bac
pourquoi est-ce que tu irais pas voir la
kabbale donc à paris olala ça j'aime
beaucoup moi il est où mon sac je sais
pas mon sac le petit sac avec le dessin
rose celui que j'ai achetés sur rodeo en
maths que tu écoutes mais si tu t'en
souviens pas à côté du magasin de
chaussures italiennes j'ai acheté mes
styles et au vent et où tout est codé
contre l'état gère quand tu m'as tu es
la fille au comptoir non à nous poser
des questions sur ma page et on a été à
fond sur thales de designers dorés des
palais vient sera pas long ok non je
vais prendre hamma et ben va prendre
tomba qui sera beaucoup mieux que à la
cabane nous retourner sur le chemin
frigorifique l'a donc là tout le monde
sait bien diviser c'est parfait comme ça
tourne pas bien mourir est les stars du
porno
nous voulons aller là la cabane là oui
j'avais oublié générateurs j'étais en
train de me draguer
fait l'invité avec nous tu vraiment quoi
non c'est quoi cette fille mais c'est la
plus grosse prostituées du chalet mais
largement battu de la région même oeil
que dans la région actuellement
donc direction la cabane le petit nid
d'amour comme ils disaient on y va
qu'est ce que t'en si elle croit qu'elle
peut s'immiscer entre nous ce qu emilie
est aussi bête qu'elle en a l'air chiant
avec un peu de chance
est ce que je lui dis emilie est une
garce fais ce que je dis dans sois sympa
avec emilie voilà parce que lui je suis
sûr qu'il aime envers son ex
[Musique]
vas-y doucement elle a du mal à se
remettre
c'est pas mon problème et ses bleus
tient non plus
[Musique]
ouais oublie ok je m'écrase est ce que
c'est de ma faute si elle comprend pas
quand je lui dis je deviens un soin
d'ouvrir exactement comme elle ça c'est
horrible je crois que ce truc a besoin
d'énergie
bah oui nous a dit d'activer les attend
là il est au générateur et là bas à
gauche
allez on y va pour toi [ __ ] imbéciles
c'est ça il ya un truc par terre c'est
quoi fabrice un totem c'est la mort
non allez on a beau les plombs et a
laissé les marchés n'avaient pas fait
magicien
oh il était là mon gars il était là bas
est un générateur est la complice
système [ __ ] j'ai peur j'ai peur je
redoute j'ai envie mais je redoute aussi
le mois on va voir ces [ __ ] de tueurs
tuer quelqu'un ça se trouve il n'y a pas
qu'un tueur s'en vient il était de
plusieurs mètres j'ai peur je suis pas
serein on va tomber nez à nez avec elle
comme on dit
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi
qui a crié quête qui était parti seul
dans ses passes et cela touche pas
possible alors il est qui il reste le
mec et la fille sont allés chercher
leurs affaires par terre pas moyen que
je reparte au chalet du musée ni sauveur
héroïque
allez on est des héros on dit ben
j'arrive pas j'avais ce connard de
tueurs dao à voile a élevé le réflexe
naturel non je vais pas en cet endroit
je fuis mais on essaye d'aller je
comprends pas dans un dans une sorte de
cabane en amoureux
comme ça j'arrête parce que ça na waie
mais qu'est ce que ça fait là un totem a
pas noir par où je t'adore pas rouge pas
de repas rouge peut-être de chance une
chance présentera quand je serai
parterre à moitié à poil dans un endroit
chaud louvre dans une cage ok droite ou
gauche droite
voilà il est juste débouchés voilà h
avec l avoir lundi si c'est quoi lundi
si c'est un cigare mais c'est l'état qui
avait cirque avait bluffé ses récents
mais c'est le qg du psychopathe bon gars
je veux bien
j'ai pas pensé l'on va mettre les sous
titres voilà annonce casse après cette
petite boule qui vous a fait bien peur
c'est quoi ça c'est des plans aulas le
plomb ce chèque carte des dangers de la
mine
voilà on est sortis plus tard mais du
coup faudra repasser par là pour
rejoindre nos amis c'est ça le problème
en fait elle est directe sur la petite
cabane au fond des bois en mad love
story oh non on va voir les deux autres
y regarder la cac
les quoi voir à quoi j'ai fait quelques
uns dans la cabane
moi je vois personne
la hervé un à droite
c'est quoi cette blague là
quelle époque
plus trop de lait de poule ou quoi non
elle a vu quelqu'un vers mike vu sa tête
avec quelqu'un écoute là on est à raison
les passerelles mais ça va pas et sachez
pas comme ça va péter les gens mais je
vous dis ça a pété avant la fin de cet
épisode je le sens yasser le service des
bus qui m'a fait pour me saouler avec
l'escrimeur il ya qu un seul puits début
du jeu [ __ ] mon sens je trouvais super
est là toute escalade et tranquillement
aller elle est par exemple grimpé égaux
dans la cabane là je suis pas sûr je
crois que tu as quelques chaussures
[Musique]
sa part en bas ça est super elle est
plus là
breizh
elle est où c'est quoi ce bordel à une
cinématique mais c'est pas le moment où
passait vraiment et jesse de gens très
tard au moment où ça commence est
intrigant pour les deux autres
on revient sur sa gauche allez quoi pour
qu'on les trouve pour leur demander là
où la chaudière au l'assassin 20 10 ça
c'est quoi une caméra vainqueur
meilleurs films d'horreur 2009
réalisateur bob washington le monastère
ensanglanté tonique et alcoa et ça c'est
la maison de smite je suis à peu près
sûr que dans cette bicoque de folie on
avait un plateau de soutien actif aux
noms mais qu'elle s'allie des atouts de
ce qu'elles s'élevaient à invoquer ce
serait une connerie mais ça marche
jamais je te dis que si mais qu on les
faisait tout le temps on a chaud des
genres ouais ouais ouais mais pas et
d'esprit serait ouais je vais allumer la
chaudière
l eos ou sa base y aller je t'attends
bon alors essayé de trouver comme de
spiritisme
c'est n'importe quoi alors c'est une
balade vers le sous-sol
waouh quel charmant balade dans une cave
et toi comme arc et comment je vais
envoyer crise et h ambitions tous les
cas elle essaie de faire des coups que
cg déjà croire qu'un peu de temps seul
leur ferait du bien
c'est vraiment une bande de potes avec
chacun leurs relations les uns les
autres quoi moqueuse crise doit se
lancer flatteuse
ils sont tellement mignons ils sont
mignons ils sont mignons ah bah on peut
être 12
rafini ont tous les deux j'espère juste
qu'ils vont continuer sinon je crois
qu'ils ont seulement besoin d'un coup de
pouce qui les rapproche de voir une
sorte d'expérience choquante qui les
jettent dans les bras l'un de l'autre
ah ben là je pense qu'ils vont être
servis ils sont bientôt les ça compte
vraiment beaucoup pour moi de revenir
ici cette année
et puis que toi tu sois là ça mal à
l'aise de confiante
on est là pour lui voilà ses deux soeurs
sont mortes h on est là pour toi
vraiment peu importe comment et quand on
va tout surmonté ça je m'en passe
doublée oui on passe un bon moment
s'inquiète pas n'empêche que l'année
dernière du coup personne n'a su mais
moi j'ai fait l'option lâcher mais en
fait j'aurais pu demander aux mecs de me
sauver quoi y'en a qu'une journée qui
seraient mortes
non mais là on est dans le sous-sol du
sceau de la bad caf quoi alors il est où
josh on l'a perdu de vue non c'est bon
désolé de ramener à la dure réalité
donne moi juste un peu d'eau chaude et
je serai aux anges
écoute j'aimerais tant que vivier
[Musique]
ça craint le pire endroit du monde je
peux dire ça bien sûr j'étais sale bruit
s'associent son père l'a le réalisateur
de films de rats qui dit en train de
faire vivre un truc horrible pour
commencer il va augmenter la pression de
l'eau avant de pouvoir allumer la
chaudière ok bon on fait tout ça et je
vais devoir débourser vous
allez nickel high five ou à yann
affinités qui a été créée je pense entre
les deux
c'est quoi ça avec tout ce qu'elle a
beaucoup aidé vous ça ça pourrait plein
de choses
wayne brake îlot vert je fais mon job
c'est au wahoo camarades en effet
il ya un truc derrière toi j'ai pas eu
peur on va rendre à faire genre qui
avait intrigué un lieu il ya un truc à
artois elle le fait bien
[ __ ]
bougez pas je crois
à l'aube et robert sérieusement
jarosch
rien ça
attention jeu pas plus
ah non non on va y aller tous les deux
ces demandes étaient claires comme d'hab
ça va être un [ __ ] d'animal va
inscrire le recul et me lasse pas c'est
trop haut
c'est une blague si mauvaise passe est
vrai mec
c'est une blague c'est une blague
ses blagues
c'est une blague
c'est une blague c'est un pote à nous
plus tard
[Musique]
ouais bah là y est c'est pas drôle
grosse merde
ap los colores le rituel vont tous fermé
leurs fesses alors je retourne me
doucher ou pas à et un plan tout
quelqu'un d'autre qu'est ce que tu
portes way plus à blagues nulles
non il a trop strict des esprits dans ma
boule de cristal
moi j ai bien avec toi same as on est
plusieurs millions mais on est là dans
le bain avec toi oh là là de retour chez
le psy [ __ ] les choses commencent à
s'envenimer sérieusement on a vu
plusieurs fois le tueur là cette fois je
pense que la faute en retour au chalet
c'est bon c'est ccc la découverte de
psychopathe qui tuent des gens
seulement laisse-moi en paix ils ont
plus précisément ce n'est pas en tirant
vers les gens ok ok la qualité la plus
importante - la franchise de toujours
être francs
absolument c'est quand stéphane ouais
alors qu'on est déjà franchie à temps et
m'embrouille la [ __ ] est ce moi
la franchise de la charité à
à la scea bonduelle je dirige et à la
franchise toujours quand même la charité
en fait non c'est pas surfer mais mais
j'ai pas dit ça et de sa mort et les
chiens ouais bah tant mieux aller une
fois encore je suis content oui ma
religion c'est à dire fin de cette
deuxième vidéo sur un type d'homme
j'espère que ça vous a plu on n'a pas
encore vu le tueur mais là les choses
commencent à sérieusement sont punis
mais il faut des plats qui font peur et
se trouver une table pour faire déloger
où tu as envie de faire le jeu le truc
que tu as fuck les esprits les autres
sont dans les bois ils ont mutu est
enfin c'est un bordel monstre les
prochains épisodes promettent d'être
riches en suspense et en j'ai un coup de
couteau bah ça va regarder n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo si cela vous plaît on se
retrouve très bientôt dans une prochaine
vie hautement bis
non mais plus quoi
[Musique]
oh